august 25th 1991 a 21 year old graduate
student in helsinki named linus torvalds
announces he's doing a free operating
system just a hobby won't be a big
professional thing fast forward a few
years later and that hobby evolves into
one of the most important projects in
the history of computing most operating
systems were created to make shitloads
of money that's right it's 99 it's an
incredible value but it's true it's
windows from microsoft ordered today
but linux was a revolution based on a
simple principle software should be free
and open today we'll take a look at the
weird history of linux and in the
process answer the question of why are
there so many linux distros but before
we can even talk about linux we need to
travel back to 1969. while grandpa was
dropping acid at woodstock ken thompson
and dennis ritchie were creating the
unix operating system unix was well
loved by both businesses and
universities there was one problem
though the code was owned by at t and in
1977 when uc berkeley created their own
berkeley software distribution at t sued
them that put limitations on unix
development and led to a period known as
the eunuchs wars a few years later in
1983 richard stallman creates the gnu
project which was intended to be a free
and open replacement for unix but unix
was a big complex project with hundreds
of different applications and replacing
it was no easy task over the next few
years the project recreated many of the
applications that you know and love
today tools that are often used
synonymously with linux like tar bash
and emacs just to name a few by the
early 90s gnu had all this great
software but it was missing one
essential component the operating system
kernel a complete operating system needs
a kernel to sit in between the hardware
and the software where it can allocate
cpu and memory resources to run software
applications luckily it was right around
this time that linus torwalds was
working on his hobby operating system
originally it was going to be called
free acts because the name linux was too
egotistical but as fate would have it
the admin for the ftp server at the time
didn't like the name and changed it
without his consent and the name stuck
from there on out initially linux was
released with a proprietary license that
had limitations on commercial use
however by the end of 1992 it was
released under the gnu general public
license and this gave birth to a
complete operating system that we know
today as gnu plus linux the following
year hundreds of developers jumped on
the linux project and started adapting
it to the gnu environment the beauty of
the linux kernel is that it gave
developers the ability to build custom
operating systems that felt like unix
but didn't come with the fear being sued
down the road ultimately this led to
some of the first linux distributions
like soft landing igrasil and slackware
but what is a linux distro exactly a
distro is a complete operating system
based on the linux kernel that contains
a bunch of packages and libraries and
typically a package manager to install
additional applications and possibly a
windows system if there's a gui involved
many distros might share the same
default user interface popular ui
options include gnome kde plasma mate
cinnamon and a bunch of others today
there's nearly a thousand different
linux distros out there and they've all
been customized to serve different
purposes some of them are designed for
enterprise users while others are for
home users some distros only run on
servers while others are designed for
desktop mobile and embedded devices and
each distro is usually backed by a
community that has its own set of
philosophical and technical opinions
most of these older distros are no
longer maintained and just considered
historical artifacts one exception is
slackware it had a release as recently
as 2016 and has spawned a bunch of
different variations most notably it led
to the open sousa project which remains
a very popular general purpose distro
and is usually associated with
professional power users but the most
significant distro to come out of 1993
was debian it was established by ian
murdock and its name comes from his name
combined with his ex-wife's name and its
first official release came in 1996 as
version 1.1 buzz and since then each
release contains a code name with a toy
story character a few years later it led
to the creation of advanced package tool
or apt although it was originally
developed under the code name deity the
debian community is huge and it's a
great distro today and very popular on
servers but can also be used as a
general purpose distro it's minimal and
stable which are traits that have
allowed it to father a huge number of
offspring distros some of them are
highly specialized like raspberry pi os
or steam os but by far the most popular
child of debian is ubuntu which was
first released in 2004 and is managed by
a british company called canonical it
follows a semi-annual release schedule
where each release is named after an
animal and a word with the same letter
like cosmic cuttlefish it's extremely
beginner friendly and was really one of
the first distros to open up linux to
the mainstream home computer user in
recent years though it's received a lot
of hate from the linux community for
releasing closed source software and
also selling data to third-party
companies in any case it remains
extremely popular and it even has a
variety of different flavors like
kubuntu zubuntu and lubuntu which are
their own distributions that offer
slight variations on the original like
kubuntu for example it's designed to be
a great entry point if you're
transitioning from microsoft windows to
linux in addition ubuntu has spawned
many other variations like linux mint
peppermint and pop os just to name a few
of the most popular options debian has a
huge family tree but if we go back to
1994 there is another linux distro that
also has a huge family tree called red
hat it was created by mark ewing and is
known for its focus on security and
reliability for enterprise users red hat
adopted a business model where they
maintain an open source operating system
then make money by selling consulting
integration and add-on services to big
enterprise clients today it generates
billions of dollars in revenue and was
recently acquired by ibm for an
11-figure price tag red hat has given
birth to a bunch of children most of
which are associated with enterprise
work and use either the rpm or yum
package manager popular descendants
include rhel sent os and fedora which is
not only great for enterprise servers
but also works well as a personal
workstation and it's even the distro of
choice by linus torvalds himself now one
thing that you'll notice about linux
distros is that many of them do a lot of
stuff that you don't actually need that
takes up space on your hardware and
ultimately makes your life more complex
there are two linux families that came
out in the early 2000s that are focused
on simplicity performance and minimalism
gen 2 with its enoch distro came out in
2000 and arch came out in 2002. if you'd
like to keep things simple then you'll
probably like the arch family of linux
distros it has its own package manager
called pacman and has adopted a rolling
release model unlike ubuntu that has a
new major release every 6 months arch
releases small updates that can be
continuously updated in the os arch is
also the parent of manjaro which is one
of the most popular distros of today in
addition to all these families that
we've looked at there are many popular
independent distros like the extremely
lightweight alpine fire os for amazon
devices and android which is used by
billions of people every day when you
think of the linux kernel like the
engine in your car it starts to answer
the question of why are there so many
linux distros some cars are designed to
go fast others for comfort some are
engineered for enterprise and others are
just for fun as a developer linux is
like a free engine that you can use to
build your own car that freedom along
with gnu and the greater open source
ecosystem motivates people to try new
things and to profit by creating
innovation within that ecosystem people
who are threatened by it call it
communism but in reality it's the polar
opposite and the free market at its
finest today even microsoft fully
supports linux through its wsl project
i'm gonna go ahead and wrap things up
there there's a lot of aspects of the
linux history and the histories of
individual distros that we didn't cover
but hopefully this gives you a general
idea of how linux came into existence
and the evolution of linux distros over
time oh and there's one random thing i
almost forgot back in 2005 the source
code for linux was managed under a
version control system called bitkeeper
that was controversial though because
it's proprietary software so linus
torvalds did what any legend would do
and he created get before you go make
sure to like and subscribe and stay
tuned for a lot more linux content on
this channel thanks for watching and i
will see you in the next one